what's going on guys this is rob and
this is one of those videos that i want
to make just to kind of get a feel for
whether or not you guys are interested
in this kind of thing right so recently
ryan hurst who is an actor that really
gained a lot of fame in the sons of
anarchy show which was amazing he came
out and said that he wanted to play the
century robert reynolds in the mcu and
as you guys can imagine this has given
way to a lot of discussion on the
internet that you guys have probably
noticed where a lot of people are asking
one why haven't we gotten the sentry in
the mcu yet two are we gonna get him
soon and three if we do
who's gonna play him now more recently
daniel craig is apparently being eyed
for some kind of a role in the marvel
cinematic universe this is entirely
speculation no one knows if it's
actually the case or not so that's not
something that i would run with it's
kind of found its way into discussions
about the century as to whether or not
daniel craig should play that character
honestly i think he'd be a terrible
choice for the century despite the fact
that he was a really cool james bond
they're distinctly different characters
and i think ryan hurst is a much better
choice but this really also begs the
question who is the sentry and why does
it matter well in the description of
this video you'll find a link to a video
over at comics explain that'll give you
an explanation that'll go into greater
detail than what we're going to cover
here but the reality is the sentry is
just the result of a ruse right it's a
trick that was played so back in 2000
there were a couple guys named paul
jenkins and j lee and they actually
wrote an inhuman story in humans volume
2 which was really really cool that was
kind of the story they had to write in
order to be able to demonstrate they
could craft a good story before they
created a character which is usually
what marvel does but when they
introduced the century they introduced
him as a quote unquote lost character
from the era of stan lee and jack kirby
which was largely believable because
they were just publishing and creating
so many characters back then it was
entirely possible that they made
somebody that just kind of slipped
through the cracks he appeared in like
some issue somewhere and was never seen
or heard from again and so what you got
was a combination of modern day
storytelling with throwbacks to the days
of stan lee and jack kirby in terms of
how the art was done and how the story
was told but the idea behind this is
that robert reynolds was basically the
superhero before seemingly all other
superheroes in more recent years that's
changed and in fact kevin grievous had
actually introduced adam beshear as the
guy who had basically stood before the
century did but that's a whole different
discussion at the time the century came
out he was the superhero right like
peter parker became spider-man became
the hero that he was partly because of
the century the fantastic four were
friends of the century and actually
attended his wedding the incredible hulk
thought the sentry was like an amazing
guy he called him the golden man they
were like super good friends but this
guy basically knew everybody but for
some reason or another he just vanished
one day and nobody knew why and not even
robert reynolds himself understood what
was going on with the sentry it's just
one day he woke up and his dog had like
this demonic voice and he attacked it
and then his wife lindy ended up leaving
him because he hit the dog and that was
basically it and so as the story
progresses what you end up finding out
is that robert reynolds was at one point
a drug addict and he had taken what was
at the time the modern iteration of the
super soldier serum that turned steve
rogers into captain america the
difference is that unlike the original
super soldier serum by abraham erskine
this one was a lot more powerful in fact
it was a thousand times more powerful
and so when he consumed it trying to get
high he turned into the century the
downside to this is that where the
century is just kind of like this
idyllic almost angel looking superhero
that the dark side of the century it's
quote unquote incredible hulk if you
want to call it that is a being called
the void and the void is basically the
entire embodiment of all the century's
powers without any inhibitions and he's
villainous right in fact the void was so
powerful it was the only thing the
incredible hulk was actually scared of
and so because of that the void ended up
returning when the sentry came back and
you end up realizing that in order to
keep the void from coming back which was
basically why this century vanished in
the first place because the void was
just attacking and destroying things all
the time that what the century along
with doctor strange and reed richards
had done is they had basically put a
beacon on top of avengers tower that
would constantly emanate a signal that
would make the world forget he existed
and when they undid that the world
recalled who this century was and
because the world knew who the century
was the void returned as well and so at
the end of the story they all basically
band together right all these
superheroes band together they fight the
void they end up having to turn the
beacon back on and the century's
forgotten again now the century was
eventually brought back in brian michael
bendis's new avengers run in a story
aptly called who is the century although
technically he appeared in the first
avengers story where elektro took down
the super villain prison the raft which
was called breakout and like he ripped
carnage in half which was amazing like
this guy destroyed carnage in like one
shot right like he flew him into space
ripped him in half and left it was crazy
but the whole story who is the century
we also covered on comics explain and
basically the void was so powerful that
a full contingent right a total coming
together of the avengers the x-men and
the fantastic four were not enough to
stop this guy right he was just on a
whole different level in terms of
strength it was absurd but the sentry is
this amazing concept in marvel because
if we're being honest with ourselves
what makes a century compelling or
interesting at least to me anyway is
that robert reynolds is basically a guy
with multiple personality disorder
schizophrenia and so when you have a
superhero out there who is basically a
superman analog that has schizophrenia
and multiple personality disorder
anything could happen the downside with
the sentry is models wrote them like
crap so you basically had stories where
like this century was defeated by
wolverine or the punisher and then you
had stories where the sentry killed loki
so it's a little weird
his power fluctuates wildly depending on
the story that's being told and a lot of
fans will tell you this century sucks
not really it's the way marvel writes
him that makes the century suck but the
century in and of himself is great and
having him added to the mcu would be
fantastic one because it's just cool to
see the sentry and two because the
marvel cinematic universe could
basically be like we make a better
superman than dc does
[Laughter]
which would be kind of funny if i'm
being honest with you guys but
regardless i think the idea of adding
somebody like that to the marvel
cinematic universe would really change
things right and you could have great
callbacks to like the early stories of
the marvel cinematic universe where you
could kind of present the scenario in
saying that where steve rogers was
believed to have been dead in the
aftermath of captain america the first
avenger and then of course was actually
frozen in ice and discovered some 70
years later during this 70-year time
period there were attempts to create new
super soldiers one of these happened to
be the century now you can follow the
comic book story to its exact notes or
you can change it up and do something
different but i feel like a character
like the century is great because one of
the things the marvel cinematic universe
lacks now is just like that guy right
like that one guy that everybody rallies
around and the comics is captain america
right i mean captain america just he's
just that guy he's got no spectacular
powers to speak of but the fact that
he's just got so much military
experience in like marshalling forces
knowing who needs to go where and what
they need to do it's cool and the marvel
cinematic universe had that i mean tony
stark was the face of the mcu but if
we're really talking about the leader of
the mcu and the various superheroes i
think we'd all kind of have to agree
it's captain america and the aftermath
of steve rogers basically having
everything that happened to him during
the events of infinity war avengers
in-game ultimately living his life out
with peggy carter showing back up in the
modern era older basically retiring
depending on what fan theory you follow
living on the blue area of the moon the
reality and the situation that we're in
right now is there's no one out there
leading the whole avengers team there's
no one to be the the guy who's in charge
we could say it's black panther but
unfortunately we know the circumstance
surrounding that so that's not a
possibility peter parker spider-man is
just too inexperienced to be a credible
leader of the team even if the mcu put
him there we wouldn't really believe it
you could say doctor strange but doctor
strange has always kind of been an
outlier out there doing his own thing
you never really saw him as somebody who
would really be a leader of the team and
so i think introducing someone like the
century or possibly hyperion or someone
like that could really go a long way in
being a kind of new captain
america-esque character where they could
basically lead the avengers as we know
them or at least the new avengers team
and just take it in a new direction but
again let me know what you guys think
about this right i mean i i love the
idea of seeing the sentry in the marvel
cinematic universe i think ryan hurst is
a great character i mean there's a lot
of fan art out there right now of ryan
hurst as the century and it looks great
right it looks absolutely amazing he
really looks the part the beard the
whole nine yards because the way robert
reynolds looked when he showed back up
in uh in the breakout storyline he was
like like grizzled had like this beard
he looked amazing
i love the way he looks right i don't
like clean face sentry right where he's
all like clean shaven and everything
it's like
i wanna i want the superhero who looks
like he's seen some things you know what
i mean like he's been around the block a
few times like he's lost some friends
lost some family he's probably had to
kill a couple people here and there like
i want the guy who's just he's he's been
down that dark path before you know like
i want that guy right just the grizzled
the grizzled dude right just just that
looking guy and and the way the sentry
looked and the way he looks when people
draw ryan hurst as the sentry he looks
great he looks absolutely fantastic so
let me know you guys think down in the
comments section thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace